journals in completeness theorem tells  us there's an infinite variety of  mathematical structure to explore  infinite it's endless and that means  there's an infinite variety of conscious  experiences to explore infinite right  yeah which is exciting so Consciousness  is exploring all of its infinite  possibilities and saying let me try on  this headset and maybe you know three  dimensions of space one dimension of  time which is what we've got is a fairly  rudimentary we think of ourselves as  sort of the exalted we if we could look  at the big picture we might realize no  no this this is a particularly simple  headset try the 50 billion Dimensions  headset well you think that chocolate  tastes good hang on a second hang on a  second exactly exactly full body orgasm  with this chocolate here you go that  that's right or you thought orgasm was  something wait till you see this